the floods have come and gone and the
Waters of the river Benway have finally
receded
the natural pace of life here seems to
have been restored but has it
Benway state is the food basket of
Nigeria Africa's most populous country
and though the deadly flooding has
passed the deeper damage will be felt in
the months ahead
and go not here men again
finish
Nigerian households rely heavily on rice
and demand has outstripped Supply in
recent years
and now flooding has hampered production
even more so we are affected by the
flood
water came
in full Bridget has been processing rice
since 2015. when I started I was
producing a ton and slightly above a ton
of rice per day
and the coming of the flood
so affected us even one to two bags we
cannot even Mill a day now as it is
a majority of Nigeria states have been
impacted by unprecedented flooding that
destroyed houses and left more than a
million homeless it's this damage to a
developing economy that is at the heart
of the climate Justice debate and at
this year's climate conference activists
are demanding Western Nations pay their
ecological debt look at the number of
people that have died already you want
to wait until everyone in Africa is dead
this is the time for climate Justice and
climate Justice is human rights look at
the the farmers
is not easy all your income will go
within one day
we met farmers who have lost everything
just a few of thousands who have seen
their farmlands washed away
all around here are crops that have been
damaged by torrential rains that left
this land flooded for around a month and
even though the flood waters have
receded these are rice crops that are
unharvestable in a country that relies
on the crop to feed its population
is almost a hundred percent loss because
there will be no Harvest
so there's nothing usable there is
nothing usable here
this gun is gone
the most fertile land in the country now
waterlogged
the rice could not stand
the pressure of the water
and at the end of the day we understand
that the whole thing has somehow dried
so much rotten and everything has gone
look at it
so almost every home is rice
so but you can see thousands of hectares
of rice are washed away so it is it's a
signal that we experience hunger next
year
it's not just Farmers here assessing the
damage
families rifle through the rot for
anything they can Mill and eat at home
and as world leaders discuss climate
change hunger tightens its grip
Sky News benue state